wie ihr vielleicht wisst habe ich schon
das ein oder andere richtig krasse
selbst experiments durchgezogen und zb
eine woche lang für nur einen euro pro
tag gegessen oder fünf tage am stück in
der virtuellen realität gelebt wobei ich
die brille nicht mal zum schlafen
abgenommen habe dabei gehe ich immer
wieder an meine eigenen grenzen es gibt
aber auch experimente die die grenzen
des legalen oder das moralisch machbaren
so weit überschreiten dass sie nicht auf
diesem kanal hochladen kann und diese
stelle ich euch heute vor aber erst
klären wir mal die frage wieso sollte
man überhaupt recht machen wollen die
entweder illegal oder moralisch nicht
ganz so sauber sind wenn ich oder
anderes experiment youtuber krasse
experimente umsätzen tun wir das in der
regel nicht nur weil diese experiment
irgendwie klasse und cool sind sondern
dahinter steckt meistens die idee euch
als zuschauer eine erfahrung
nachvollziehen zu lassen die man
normalerweise nicht selber machen will
oder oft auch nicht selber machen sollte
da gebe es zum beispiel tomaten mit
seinen drogen reportagen oder yes
theorie die sogar nach afghanistan
geflogen sind das land welches aktuell
als das gefährlichste der welt gilt und
eine reise von der einem die meisten
menschen wohl eher abraten würden aber
dadurch dass sie diese persönlichen
grenzen überschreiten bieten die videos
millionen von menschen einen mehrwert
denn ohne selbst risiko einzugehen hat
eine million zuschauer die möglichkeit
die afghanische kultur kennenzulernen
und womöglich vorurteile abzulegen es
gibt aber auch projekte die durch
persönlichen einsatz konkrete missstände
aufdecken so hat zb der youtuber marvin
will tage sich mit einer selbst
erstellten doktor urkunde einen
doktortitel im personalausweis
erschlichen und so gezeigt wie unsauber
in manchen ämtern gearbeitet wird nun
drohen ihm dafür 40 tage haft oder eine
geldstrafe für etwas was natürlich
illegal meiner meinung nach im rahmen
seiner journalistischen arbeit aber
vollkommen in ordnung ist da es gezeigt
hat wie leicht man das system
austricksen konnte niemanden geschadet
hat und dieser missstand dadurch
hoffentlich schneller behoben wird
eigentlich bedenkliche versuche können
also durchaus gerechtfertigt sein und
einen mehrwert bieten trotzdem habe ich
persönlich einige ideen die ich so
wahrscheinlich in der praxis niemals
veröffentlichen sollte wie zb der
wahrsagers gern viele kennen sicherlich
die freelancer plattform fall war auf
der selbständige so gut wie der art von
dienstleistung anbieten seien es
programmierer synchronsprecher minecraft
map bauer oder aber auch wahrsager diese
bieten dann an die zukunft des
auftraggebers zu lesen einen
liebeszauber zu wirken haare per magie
wieder wachsen zu lassen oder besonders
geschmacklos und für stolze 32 euro
kontakt mit einem geliebten verstorbenen
menschen aufzunehmen meiner meinung nach
ist das ziemlich offensichtlich betrug
mit dem verzweifelten menschen geld aus
der tasche gezogen wird ich werde sie
aber trotzdem super spannend zu sehen
wie diese mentalisten dabei vorgehen und
mit diesen techniken eben auch geld als
wahrsager zu verdienen einfach irgendwo
möglich zu zeigen wie leicht das geht
und wie die käufer darauf reagieren denn
auch wenn es aus meiner sicht abzocke
ist sind die bewertungen der war sogar
oft ziemlich gut und eventuell hilft es
ja einigen konnten tatsächlich zu hören
dass ihre verstorbenen an sie denken
oder dass sie bald ihren traumpartner
kennen lernen und genau deshalb es halt
schon ultra spannend herauszufinden wie
sich so ein wahrsager dabei überhaupt
fühlt wenn er solche reaktionen in
seinen kunden auslösen kann das jeder
machen oder muss man dafür ein
abgebrühter betrüger sein so ein video
wird super viel aufklärungsarbeit in
diese richtung leisten und bestimmt
einigen menschen dabei helfen nicht auf
wasser heranzufahren nachdem sie gesehen
haben dass sogar nicht die leute dazu
bringen kann zu glauben ich sei ein
echter wahrsager die beiden punkte
weswegen ich das projekt trotzdem nicht
machen werde ist erstens will ich damit
leuten das geld aus der tasche ziehen
für was meiner meinung nach hat einfach
keinen nutzen hat und zweitens würde ich
womöglich sogar jemand davon abhalten
sich professionelle hilfe zu suchen und
das kann ich aktuell zumindest nicht mit
mir vereinbaren einen ausweis fälschen
ein deutscher personalausweis hat 23
sicherheitsmerkmale darunter hologramm
mit ihnen bestimmten winkeln bestimmte
muster und symbole ergeben makro
schriften 3d bilder farben die sich je
nach lichteinfall verändern und noch
viel viel mehr damit ist es quasi
unmöglich ihn perfekt zu fälschen ganz
abgesehen davon dass auch hier wieder
geldstrafen und bis zu fünf jahre haft
drohen trotzdem war es wirklich extrem
spannend herauszufinden ob man so ein
ausweis selber fälschen kann zumindest
so gut geht finden sich dafür
anleitungen im internet und vor allem
will ich damit bei sicherheitskontrollen
durchkommen man könnte damit er wirklich
zeigen wie gut in welche behörden oder
irgendwelche clubs und so weiter und so
fort wirklich auf unsere ausweise
kontrollieren oder ob sie nur kurz drauf
schauen und das eigene überhaupt nicht
sicher ist spannend wäre auch wie man
diese ganzen einzelnen
sicherheitsmerkmal überhaupt erstellt
welche chemikalien braucht man dafür und
woher bekommt man die man vielleicht
sogar kontakt zu einem echten fälscher
herstellen und sich von dem das zeigen
lassen wie es genau geht das gleiche wir
auch super spannend mit führerschein
oder reisepässen aber auch wenn ich das
für journalistische aufklärungszwecken
überhaupt nicht moralisch verwerflich
findet wenn man damit kein unfug
anstellen ich persönlich liebe außerhalb
eines gefängnisses ist eine woche im
gefängnis leben ist übrigens und
experiments dass ich tatsächlich mal
machen will aber dann natürlich auf den
regalen weg mit drehgenehmigung und ohne
kriminell zu werden eine eigene pistole
bauen mit einem 3d drucker kann man
natürlich allerhand kohle kleinigkeiten
ganz leicht zu hause selbst drucken aber
jeder der sich auch nur ein bisschen mit
3d druck beschäftigt hat auch schon mal
gehört dass man damit funktionierende
pistolen ebenfalls relativ leicht zu
hause herstellen kann mit nur ein paar
minuten recherchen kann also jeder
druckfertige modelle im internet finden
und sich eine potenziell tödliche waffe
basteln aber
auch eine 3d gedruckte pistole fällt in
deutschland wie jede andere unter das
waffenrecht sie darf also nicht einfach
so ohne erlaubnis hergestellt und
gesessen werden und ich bin auf super
froh dass anders als in den usa hier in
deutschland für die meisten leute waffen
kein thema sind gleichzeitig ist die
mechaniker hinter einem gegenstand auf
knopfdruck schlag als ich möglichst
schnell durch die lüfte zu feuern extrem
spannend und zielübungen egal ob mit
spielzeugpistolen pfeil und bogen oder
in computerspielen wer schon extrem
spannend und herauszufinden wie gut das
teil das ich dann bauen würde darin
abschneiden würde auch
ich hatte also einerseits schon los so
was ähnliches zu konstruieren und zu
prüfen ob das wirklich so einfach ist
und was jeder zu hause machen könnte und
ich habe auch schon überlegt nicht dass
ungefähr angehen würde da die dinge aus
kunststoff sind explodieren die nach dem
ersten schuss oft und da müsste man
natürlich welche sicherheitsvorkehrungen
treffen irgendwelche glas wenn wir uns
weiter und so fort oder sogar eine
ferngesteuerte konstruktion die das
klappt das ja noch sicherer wäre bei der
echten explodieren einfach und ich finde
jetzt auch nicht super schlimm wenn man
den zuschauern zeigen würde wie so eine
pistole funktionieren würde ich meine
die leute die das wissen wollen wir
wissen es schon und ich glaube auch
eigentlich dass die leute die sich oder
andere damit verletzen würden die
schaffen das auch so aber trotzdem kommt
das wieder nicht weil waffenbesitz ist
natürlich extrem heikel wenn man das
öffentlich zeigt müsste man das
monatelang mit anwälten vorbereiten
gegebenenfalls irgendwelche
sondergenehmigungen beantragen
und selbst dann wäre es immer noch es
kann also lass ich das lieber eine
eigene krippe währung erschaffen kann
man einfach selbst so etwas wie bitcoin
oder duschen machen das wäre ein video
dass ich nicht nur spannend finde
sondern das mit sicherheit auch gut bei
euch ankommen würde der youtuber dave
hat bereits etwas ähnliches gemacht aber
die währung aus guten gründen niemals
veröffentlicht
aber was wäre wenn man das doch
veröffentlichen würde welche wellen
würde das schlagen und wie würden die
leute darauf reagieren und natürlich
klar wie viel verdient man mit einer
eigenen krük bewährung das problem ist
nur dass meine crypto währung
wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich eine gute
werde und sich die leute das
wahrscheinlich nur meinetwegen und aus
spaß kaufen würden und ich will wirklich
dass ein teil meiner community damit
vielleicht ein bisschen viel geld
verdient aber ein anderer teil dann halt
geld verliert und einander und ein
anderer teil hat damit aber
ein anderer teil natürlich geld verliert
und selbst wenn ich sagen würde ja mach
das nicht ihr verliert wahrscheinlich
euren einsatz also selbst kein geld auf
spieler gebraucht würden das
wahrscheinlich trotzdem parade tun und
damit will ich nicht wirklich was zu tun
hatten die glitzer bomb extreme
vielleicht habt ihr schon mal eines
dieser videos gesehen mit präparierten
paketen sams gps und handykameras die
alles live mit film legt der
amerikanische youtuber marc huber paket
die wir hier ein indem er sie mit einer
glitzer explosion und mehreren anderen
kleinen gemeinheiten wie zum beispiel
einer ladung pspgo überraschte sobald
sie sich mit ihrer beute in sicherheit
wiegen uns das paket dann öffnen da habe
ich mir natürlich sofort gedacht das
geht auch krasser und besser zum ersten
hätte ich habe richtig lust zum teil zu
bauen weil ich einfach gern mechanismen
bau und zum anderen hätte ich auch schon
ideen wie man das ganze noch mal ein
gutes stück gemeinde machen könnte zum
beispiel an stelle des glitzer ist eine
schwache explosion mit nicht
abwaschbarer farbe die die klamotten und
ohne die möbel dass die bis ruiniert
oder direkt sekundenkleber und anstatt
das relativ harmlosen pucks preis
einfach pfefferspray das wahrscheinlich
erst illegal selbst wenn man irgendwie
eine grauzone finden würde in der die
diebe ja selber schuld sind weil sie das
paket selber öffnet das ja nicht ihr
paket ist er trotzdem glaube ich nicht
ganz legal und zweitens wenn ich das
ganze auch moralisch ein bisschen
schwierig weil ich natürlich trotzdem
mitgefühl haben jemanden das nötig hat
zu klauen ist trotzdem moment ruhig und
gefasst wird allerdings muss man nicht
öffentlich bloßstellen aber vielleicht
war ich ein teil trotzdem einmal und
tests an mir geld verdienen als
drogendealer ich habe ja für meine
videos schon viel gemacht um geld zu
verdienen auf fall war meine schnitt
künstler angeboten bezahlt der umfragen
machen bitcoin mining mit meinem rechner
drogen zu verticken würde da natürlich
etwas aus der reihe tanzen wäre aber
vermutlich sogar noch spannender wie
genau findet man als dealer seinen
ersten kunden wie fühlt sich das an
leute danach zu fragen ob sie stoff
kaufen wollen wie alt die kunden so wie
gefährlich ist das ganze für mich und
wie schwer ist es nicht aufzufliegen
aber natürlich auch wie schnell verdient
man damit geld so eine reportage wäre
für den zuschauer eine einmalige
gelegenheit an ein bild zu bekommen wie
so eine illegale karriere anfängt und
die sich an fangen ganz normaler mensch
derweil fühlt anderen leuten stoff an zu
drehen und wie sich dieses gefühl
vielleicht mit der zeit ändert schaut
man sich das einfach so oder macht man
da direkten rückzieher aber auf diese
art und weise werden wir wohl nie
herausfinden drogen zu verkaufen ist
nämlich wie ihr wisst illegal in
deutschland und zwar nicht nur so ein
bisschen sondern so richtig im gegensatz
zu anderen heiklen themen wie zb einem
erschlichenen doktortitel glaube ich
würde es hierbei schwer fallen selbst
für eine journalistische arbeit oder mit
anderen grauzonen durchzukommen also
kurz gesagt die nummer wäre mir ungefähr
zehn stufen zu heiß und wenn ich das
machen und auch noch veröffentlichen
würde würde ich wahrscheinlich zu fast
100 prozent in den bau wandeln denn auch
ein journalistisches interesse glaubhaft
zu begründen ist nicht immer ganz leicht
und rechtfertigt natürlich auch nicht
alles das waren also meine zu illegalen
selbst experimente die so wahrscheinlich
niemals umsetzen kann aber ich werde
weiterhin daran arbeiten vielleicht den
ein oder anderen in abgeschwächter und
illegaler varianten zu testen zum
beispiel die glitzer baum extrem einfach
an mir selber testen wenn ihr das nicht
verpassen möchte unbedingt mal bei mir
auf instagram in der video beschreibung
vorbei da seht ihr meine stories
eigentlich immer als allererstes was ich
für den wahnsinn ball anstellt und
abonniert main kanal dann sehen wir auch
beim nächsten video im neuen jahr wieder
uns damit wünsche ich euch guten rutsch
[Musik]